翻訳: Emi Suzuki
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
今日は 写真の可能性について
皆さんにお話しします
硬くて ごわごわした 大きな手
これは 日系ブラジル人の
現場作業員の手
日本のものづくりを支える手
あなたの車 あなたの家電
あなたの持っているものを
作ったかもしれない手
1990年
今から約30年前 法律が変わって
日系ブラジル人がたくさん日本に来ました
日系三世までの人たちが
日本で働くことを認められたからです
景気の良い日本で働くことを目的に来る
「デカセギ」です
さっきの手の持ち主も
1990年に日本にデカセギに来た
日系ブラジル人の ひなたさんです
ここで 約30年前の
デカセギ労働者の暮らしに
タイムスリップしてみましょう
（チャイム）
始業のベルが鳴る
指差し確認「安全よし！」
危険 汚い きつい
３Kと呼ばれる仕事でも
日本人が嫌がる夜勤でも
すすんでやった
ミスをしないように
不良を出さないように
丁寧にやること
時間を守ること
日本人とブラジル人の間には
いろんな違いがある
言葉が分からない中で
仕事をするのは 大変
作業着は 今日も真っ黒になった
タバコ休憩 ほっと一息
こうして １日が終わる
家に帰ったら 狭いキッチンで料理をする
ブラジルに残してきた家族には
いつ会えるだろうか
手紙を書いても 届くのは 半月先
携帯電話なんて 便利なものはない
はやる気持ちを胸に
電話ボックスの列に並ぶ
これが 30年前の
デカセギ労働者の暮らしです
これは僕が撮った写真です
だけど 実際に
30年前に撮った写真ではない
30年前を再現した写真です
このプロジェクトを始めたわけを話す前に
少し 僕のことをお話しします
僕は ブラジルの港町に生まれました
おじいさんは 日本からブラジルに
渡ってきた 日系一世
ブラジルでは
カメラ屋さんをやってました
小さな頃から カメラは身近にありました
でも 本格的に写真を撮るようになったのは
日本に来てから
今から28年前
僕も デカセギ労働者として
日本に来たんです
大変なことも多かったけど
いい人にも巡り会いました
僕に写真を教えてくれたのが 滝口さんです
単調な出稼ぎ生活が
カメラを手にしたことで 少し楽しくなった
海に行ったり
モーターショーに行ったり
滝口さんとよく撮影に出かけた
でも なにか足りなかった
ただのきれいな写真じゃなくて
メッセージが感じられる—
そんな写真を撮りたいと思った
そこで 自分のルーツに立ち返った
約30年前 デカセギに来た
最初の世代の記録を残したい
このプロジェクトを始めたわけは
「あの頃に自分が体験したシーンを
記録すること」でした
最初の世代が道を拓いたから
今がある
その努力を記録したい
その努力に感謝したい
という思いを込めて
当時の再現写真を撮ることに決めました
それが 先ほど見せた写真です
このデカセギプロジェクト１を撮影するのに
３年かかりました
その後「プロジェクトを
共有したい」と思いました
写真が展示されて
最初のデカセギ世代にも
今のデカセギ世代にも
メッセージが届きました
たくさんの人に見てもらって
ブラジル人だけじゃなく
日本人にもメッセージが届きました
時代の流れとともに
デカセギは 少しずつ形を変えている
日本にずっと住む人たちも 増えてきた
今では 日本人と同じように
活躍する人たちも 出てきている
そんな 新しいデカセギ世代を撮影したのが
デカセギプロジェクト２です
モデル
料理人
大学生
相撲取り
作家
社長など
皆さんどれがだれかわかりましたか
ここには 未来への希望があります
最初のデカセギ世代は 日本の社会の中で
自分たちの小さな居場所を作りました
日本にいるブラジル人たちが
快適に生活できるように
コツコツと努力をしてきました
世代が変わり 日本語を勉強して
日本の社会で活躍する人たちも出てきました
これからのデカセギ世代は
どんな形になるでしょうか
若者たちには
パイオニアが作った環境がある
まずは しっかり 日本語を勉強すること
そして 向上心を持つこと
日本とブラジル
ふたつのアイデンティティを持った世代の
新しいデカセギ
これからは 日本の社会で
日本人とブラジル人が
一緒に活躍していけるでしょう
さて ここまで
写真の可能性を通して
デカセギの過去と未来を話してきました
写真は「真実を写す」と言いますが
本当にそれだけでしょうか
写真は 過去という記録を
残すことができます
そして 未来という希望を
写すこともできます
僕は そう思います
これからも 写真の可能性を信じて
僕も 写真を撮っていきます
（拍手）